or if I don't even actually investigate it,"
then trust your gut.
It might be time for that career change.
On the flip side,
one reason to not move on is short-term pain.
If you don't like your boss
or people at the office are grating on you,
that's actually not a good reason to absolutely change your career,
because when you do change a career,
you generally have to start from the bottom,
and you'll probably feel a lot of short-term pain,
whether it's through a lack of salary or lack of a title.
Pain at any job is inevitable.
So now you're convinced that it's time to change your career.
Then there's three things to do immediately.
First: network, network, network.
No one ever builds a career without a good mentor
or a good support network.
What I mean by networking is getting all the great advice
that you can possibly get.
Technology has made it so simple to reach out to new people
to say, "Hey, I'm thinking about making a career change.
Do you have just five minutes to chat with me?"
That passion and that hunger and that ability to be a sponge
really attracts awesome mentors
and people willing to give you their time
to give you some good advice.
So go out there and meet new people.
The second thing you need to do immediately
is shore up your finances.
The reality is, when you change your career,
you'll either start with a job with a lower title
or lower pay or maybe even no pay,
especially if you're starting your own business.
So going out there and making sure your finances are in order
to make the transition less painful
is really, really important.
For me personally, as I made the transition from being an attorney
over to a video game creator,
I wanted to have at least six to 12 months of personal runway in the bank.
Six to 12 months might not be the right number for you,
but be honest with yourself on what that number should be.
Number three, if you're not ready to make the full jump right at this moment,
then get your side hustle on.
Side hustles could be anything from volunteering with an organization
that's in the new industry you want to go into,
could be starting your business part-time on the weekends.
It's a free way to get a taste to see if you really love something.
So you're ready to make the move
or maybe you already made the move.
Here are three things you should think about doing, right now.
One: do not -- I repeat -- do not burn bridges.
You spent years building those bridges,
why burn them now?
The world is such a small place,
especially with all these online platforms,
that, believe me, you will see these people again
and probably in the most inopportune times.
Number two: take stock of what you've learned
in your previous career or careers.
Most likely, a lot of those things are really applicable
to your new job and your new career,
whether it's interacting with people, playing on a team
or dealing with jerks and assholes.
All those things are really universally applicable.
You'll find jerks no matter what industry you're in;
no one's immune to it, everyone's got to figure it out,
and you probably know how to do it already.
Lastly, when you start your new job, you're going to be nervous.
But don't worry, take a deep breath,
because this is what I want to tell you:
you're part of a new team now,
and everyone around you is rooting for your success,
because your success is their success.
So welcome to your new career.